y avez vous déjà eu recours à la
chirurgie esthétique sur un autre visage
bon ben je réponds très facilement vous
avez dit non déjà mais oui je maintiens
non mais non je vous dis pas ce qu'ils
ont fait des expériences 0 par des
expérimentations
commenté pète chimie ils ont près avec
baser nos frères abattus byada plus
spécialement et s'adonner à ça mais
c'est
donc alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé
ça m'arrange pas frères
nous a demandé de jouer dans une
publicité faite aux états unis d'accord
qui devait d'abord deux objectifs 1 nous
distinguer l'un de l'autre et deux et ça
c'est le point important qu'on n'a
jamais dit et c'est la première fois
qu'on le nie
la foi qui en appelle d'autres
et en fait ils ont dit mais on va
accentuer et c'est vrai qu'on s'est vus
sur toutes les affiches là bas et dans
tous les réseaux venant d'une autre
planète ah oui oui non mais c'est vrai
je vous ai donc pris donc ils ont fait
une des expériences simplement des
expérimentations sur des rayonnements en
fait il y un abonnement ce sont environ
deux tonnes des longueurs d'onde qui
sont plus ou moins pénétra emporté même
gérer servi de cobayes en fait aux
américains oui c'est ouf ah ouais
bah là ça n'a pas trop bougé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pat music
non mais c'est vrai qu'on a entendu à
peu près tout et n'importe quoi moi je
crois en fait qu'il avait vraiment envie
de ne pas être tout le monde il avait
envie d'être des sortes de petites
princesses quoi vraiment je me tourne
vers la spécialiste les peines fermes
et tombèrent boucané qui connaissait le
lâcher les choses oui j'avais envie
d'être bête différents à baisser assez
sûr qu'ils étaient différents en sa
famille et je pense qu'il ya eu une
maîtrise sur un comme on dit que c'est
excessif quoi le l'époque tout cas il ya
les pommettes ya les dents il ya le nez
il ya les faits la chirurgienne qui
parle la wii mhp l'analyse spatiale
d'accord mais je connais à peu près
toutes les opérations menées sur les
lèvres on a tout et tout est refait oui
daniel non en fait il est très attention
à leur apparence physique et grichka par
exemple était capable de manger un
yaourt au soja dans la journée seulement
pour garder sa sa ligne et on les a vus
plusieurs fois là dans les extraits avec
leurs combinaisons là mais moi j'ai eu
la chance de les interviewer il ya deux
mois à peine pour un documentaire les
héros de notre enfance parce que c'est
vraiment des héros de notre enfance et
il était venu avec la combinaison
d'époque c'est à dire qu'il y avait 40
ans de temps lisez ses traits louis
exactement l'idée qu'elle avait été
plongé dans l'azoté liquide et voilà la
photo regardez c'est la combinaison des
pas et il était très fier parce qu'il
pouvait encore rentré dedans 40 ans plus
tard et alors j'ai vécu une scène ça
c'est moi a tourné au musée grévin est
en fait au musée grevin faut savoir que
le téléphone va la faire comme disait
vous voulez que
je raconterai sur internet
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ces magiciens et mon type moi je
m'assure que je suis sûr que s'ils nous
regardent de là-haut les bogdanoff un
très très bel automne marque soit dans
l'écran ce soir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
m